Công chình chân vô thông lộ chú liên cấp đều học và Trung học cơ sở năng hoàn.
Có quy mô dịch liệt khoảng năm 2018, với tổn vốn đồ tư gần 2 chăm 1 mới đi động,
từng 1 vốn nhả nước và sã hội ngoã.
Công chình được lấu tư dạng đại đồng bộ với 1 mới chiến lế học mà các khu ký tuốc xa nhả ăn,
khu vù trời, khu trả nhẹp, khu tăng xa sản xuất.
Khi đi về hoạt động, công chình giúp hơn 1 in chính trăm học sinh, khu vực viên dưới học lập
phát triển toàn diện về chi thức kỹ năng thể chất tinh thần và nhân cách.
Công có phòng ăn nền của vực viên giới, tại lẽ khơi công,
còn bị thư tổn lập nhảnh mạnh.
Bịt lâu tư dạng 2 chăm 1 mới tảm chừng nội chú liên cấp là một trụ trường đúng đắn,
có những nhiễn văn sâu sắc.
Thế hiện sự quan tâm đặc biệt của đảng nhả nước lối với đồng bảo vùng viên giới,
cùng sâu vùng xa, con nhiều có khăn.
Xe dự trường lớp không chỉ để các cháo có điều kiện học tập tốt hơn,
mà còn hướng tới bục tiêu lâu dài, là năng cấp chất lợi dưới sống nhân dân vùng viên giới,
có phần giữa sinh chủ quyền lãnh thổ quốc gia từ cốc sẽ,
nó là con người là cốc đồng rất cơ,
gắn bỏ với đất với dần với đình viên của tốt mốc.
Tổn bị thư tổn lập tình hiếc,
các bụng ngành chung gần của hợp trạch chẽ với cấp oi,
chính quyền địa phương, giả lăng, chương bản, lực lượng vũ trang,
để vận động nhân dân cùng trong lo sự nghiệp sáo dục.
Xeam chừng học là pháo đại của chi thức phân quá,
và lòng yêu nước ở bên dưới.